que marc lynch a pas pour parler de son
nouveau milices ministère délégué à la
citoyenneté vous avez déclaré ce matin
que vous serez la ministre qui va porter
la laïcité
et ça tombe bien les sénateurs
travaillent sur ce sujet et il dénonce
notamment et bien l'omniprésence de
l'islam radical dans certains quartiers
est ce que vous êtes d'accord avec ce
diagnostic
d'abord effectivement je suis délégué
chargé de la citoyenneté et notamment
j'entends porter les valeurs de la
république parmi lesquels le principe de
laïcité qui est fondamental pourquoi
parce que la laïcité c'est un bouclier
qui nous permet à vous et moi par
exemple d'être considérés comme des
citoyens indifféremment de notre
religion
je ne connais pas vous appartenance
religieuse ou non vous ne connaissez pas
les miennes et les gens qui nous
regardent non pas à les connaître
parce que c'est du domaine de la sphère
privée et ça ça nous permet d'être
considérés comme des citoyens et c'est
important
ensuite les sénateurs ont mené un
travail auquel vous faites référence est
un rapport notamment
on va bien sûr il travaille avec le
ministre de l'intérieur puisque nous
préparons un projet de loi de lutte
contre les séparatismes et nous
entendons y travailler avec l'ensemble
des parlementaires qu'il s'agisse des
sénateurs lr qui siège en ce moment et
qui ont travaillé sur ce rapport ou des
sénateurs et des députés
d'autres bords politiques notamment bien
sûr de la majorité mais également de
l'opposition vous êtes d'accord avec le
diagnostic il ya un problème de laïcité
dans certains quartiers alors moi je
crois que la laïcité n'est pas assez
défendu et ça je les dis de longue date
ça fait des années que je bataille pour
que la laïcité soit au coeur des débats
politiques que nous menons j'ai coécrit
un livre qu'il avait laïcité points pour
défendre ce principe de laïcité nous
avons organisé à la république en marge
des débats est d'ailleurs à cette
occasion il y avait une étude ifop
fondation jean jaurès qui montrait que
plus de 70% des français considéraient
que la laïcité n'était pas assez défendu
par les responsables politiques
donc quand le premier ministre jean
castex s'exprime dans sa première
interview de premier ministre en disant
moi ce qui me définit ce sont les
valeurs de la république et c'est
notamment la défense du principe de
laïcité
eh bien je crois que c'est un message
très fort qu'il adresse au pays et sur
l'islam radical vous avez le combattre
mais bien sûr la lutte contre les
séparatismes c'est aussi évidemment une
lutte contre le séparatisme islamistes
d'ailleurs le gouvernement a d'ores et
déjà fait fermer près de 300 endroits
problématiques de
les débuts du quinquennat je pense à des
débits de boissons je pense à des écoles
qui prêchait justement ce séparatisme et
que les précédents gouvernements avec
gérard collomb et ensuite à christophe
castaner ont fait fermer justement pour
lutter contre le séparatisme je crois
qu'il faut maintenant continuer et
amplifier cette action est ce que vous
serez toujours la ministre qui luttera
contre eux les violences faites aux
femmes
je crois que quand on est féministe
depuis l'adolescence comme c'est mon cas
et j'ai maintenant 37 ans et je suis
mère de famille et merde adolescente moi
même on n'arrête pas d'être féministe
heureusement dans le pays il ya beaucoup
de féministes et pas seulement la
ministre chargée de l'égalité
femmes-hommes donc je crois que ce
gouvernement
il porte la grande cause du quinquennat
pour l'égalité femmes hommes
la mise de l'égalité femmes hommes bien
évidemment mais aussi par exemple la
ministre des sports qui mène un combat
courageux contre les violences sexuelles
dans le sport à l'espagnol une hache à
la mise de l'industrie qui se bat pour
la place des femmes dans ce secteur
habituellement plutôt masculin et en ce
qui me concerne j'ai la responsabilité
au ministère de l'intérieur de
l'engagement des forces de l'ordre dans
la protection des femmes
vous savez que partout les forces de
l'ordre sont en première ligne pour
protéger les femmes face aux violences
intrafamiliales s'asseoir scellement de
rue face aux violences sexuelles et cet
engagement des 290 1000 personnes du
ministère de l'intérieur
je veux le porter et l'incarné bien sûr
avec gérald darmanin dernière question
une chappe à qui concerne votre ministre
de tutelle gérald darmanin ou de la
deûle enquête pour viol qu'est ce que
vous pensez
sur le fait qu'un homme échange des
passes trop des passe-droits contre des
faveurs sexuelles c'est ce qu'a reconnu
gérald darmanin et ses avocats alors
d'abord moi il me semble que j'ai vu
passer hier un communiqué de ses avocats
qui disait au contraire qu'il n'avait
pas reconnu cela mais en tout cas moi
j'observe qu'il y a eu ni nier cette
ligne c'est la justice à dire est ce
qu'il ya un moment quelqu'un qui est
coupable ou innocent la justice a rendu
de non lieu un classement sans suite je
crois qu ensuite le reste et les
commentaires sur les fantasmes de la vie
réelle ou supposée personnelle intime de
chacun je crois qu'on a vue dernièrement
à quel point ça ne servait pas le débat
public ce que je peux vous garantir
c'est que moi je peux 100 % des femmes
puissent déposer plainte quand elles ont
été victimes de violences quelles que
soient ses audiences que c'est plein de
fils est prise
et puis s'être qualifiés qu'elles
puissent être transmises et qu'ensuite
la justice puisse passer et ça c'est
l'engagement que je porte au ministère
de l'intérieur
très bien merci beaucoup mind charline
chapin d'avoir répondu à m